some of us might be getting confused by what princess treatment is
princess treatment isn't in the gifts that he buys you
if he pays for your nails
if he pays for your hair takes you on lavish shopping trips
or takes you on vacation that is not princess treatment
real princess treatment is in the way he holds you emotionally
Does he validate you emotionally
is he genuinely kind
Does he actually care when you get upset and cry
He doesn't let you go to bed upset
He doesn't raise his voice at you
he's soft and gentle with you
that is princess treatment
yeah gifts are nice
most women are happy when you do gift them things
however I wouldn't consider that princess treatment
Real princess treatment is in his emotional maturity